[Music]
at google our services and products run
on a globally distributed computing
system made up of many machines and data
centers
they're all linked to a large scale
network that's core to what makes google
services including google cloud run
so how does google's data center
networking work
first you need to understand the size of
our network
google's network supports a one petabit
per second bisectional bandwidth to put
that in perspective you could transfer
the entirety of wikipedia in under a
second
or enough bandwidth to read the entire
scanned contents of the library of
congress in less than 1 10 of a second
while i could talk about the fiber optic
cables or physical switches we use the
real power comes from how we manage
traffic at scale
see the networking between data centers
is built with diverse pathways of fiber
interconnecting data centers points of
presence or local network access points
and even continents through subsea
cables
we need to ensure data centers can talk
to each other for resilience so we can
serve traffic close to our users and
customers
to do that we use our global wide area
network
our goal is to create enough redundancy
and capacity of the overall network to
reduce traffic congestion in any one
area and withstand any network failures
that's why at our data centers we've
invested in not just one fiber link out
of a building but many fiber links to
provide more pads and redundancy to our
long-haul network or wide area network
so what's happening within the data
centers once traffic passes through
these links
our data center network fabric is made
up of a closed hierarchical switching
fabric we designed called jupiter which
connects hundreds of thousands of
machines across data center buildings
machines at the data center have
physical connections for switching into
jupiter and all traffic flowing through
jupiter is controlled by a central
software defined controller
jupiter is able to provide such large
bandwidth because it's non-blocking
which means it can handle routing a
request to any free output port without
interfering other traffic
this means it can scale or burst with
extremely low latency and is capable of
building resilience if something in the
fabric breaks it can handle disruptions
so where does google cloud traffic fit
into all of this
andromeda is a virtualized software
defined network built on top of jupiter
giving you your very own slice of our
massive global switching fabric
andromeda enables you to deploy a
virtual private cloud network giving you
both functional and performance
isolation and a high degree of security
with its global control plane high speed
on host virtual switch and packet
processors you can burst thousands of
stateful machines online in minutes or
deploy firewall rules across thousands
of machines immediately without choke
points
and because compute and storage are
separated and talk to each other through
the network they can scale independently
so you get virtually unlimited storage
and stateless resilient compute
whether you're processing petabytes of
data in seconds using bigquery running
consistent databases across regions
using spanner or auto scaling gke
clusters across zones google's data
centers and global network backbone
together make these technologies
impressive
if you want to learn more check out
cloud.google.com
networking
[Music]